director of Guardians of the
[Applause]
[Music]
Galaxy welcome guys welcome Hey down
please take a please take a seat look
how Zoe
looks she looks amazing amazing
right look how pretty they looks they
they looks amazing as well you know uh
James maybe you want to unbutton your
shirt as
well now let me not read back the
profile that you all have seen of James
I told that the filmmakers were looking
for a Visionary director who could
deliver a well balanced mix of humor
emotion and action uh while working with
unique characters and his job is then to
bring them to life in an unexpected
unique and threedimensional way wow well
done J thanks okay I'm judging by how
they enjoyed the 17 minute clip earlier
on you're a legend now James welcome to
Singapore um we hope you're well rested
for your j i I got great great sleep
last night have you seen the giant
baby have you seen the giant baby we
have that's my favorite thing I've ever
seen in my entire life is the giant baby
what is that that you know what it's
called thing I'm not sure but I know it
did cause a little bit of a stir people
didn't like it like well let's just put
it this way not everyone Lov it I love
it I love
it okay now James in most markets here
in Asia uh we love action movies and uh
we hear you're a big fan of of of of
comedy of humor okay and I just want you
to know that here in Asia we love that
mix if it's an action movie and it's got
humor in it people don't just catch
these movies one once they catch it more
than once so um how much Shima have you
packed into Marvel's Guardians of the
Galaxy James well I think that really
Guardians of the Galaxy is about the
characters and I think that these
characters are in and of themselves
funny so it wasn't so much a matter of
me trying to pack in the comedy it was
just letting these characters and these
actors here fully Express themselves so
that the humor was able to come out in a
natural way and it's interesting is of
Asia cuz I really you know a lot of the
films that influenced Me growing up and
today are are Asian films where they're
you know the films of of Korea or China
or Japan I really have found that those
movies deal better than American films
with that mix of action and comedy um
and I think that uh hopefully Guardians
is a way to sort of mix that Eastern uh
influence with with the Western
influence of Marvel thank you very much
James and uh something about action and
all that I think one of the most
difficult characters to come from what I
understand was the character of DRS so
here we go Mr Dave
Batista can we have another big round of
applause should I just refer to you as
champ you can if you
want been called champ few now now folks
dra is quite an intense character it was
also a group Warrior it was uh a for the
studio to work with a globally known
wrestler uh but they found a perfect D
inap Mr Dave Batista now once again
welcome to Singapore Dave uh thank you
so much for increasing the average
height of people here in Singapore for
this week at
least and we are indeed thrilled to have
you here are you aware of your crazy fan
base in this country um it's weird um
you
know I I don't realize it anywhere I go
you know it's always still weird to me
when people walk up they know who I am
you know I think I don't know just kind
of did you see the people out there with
the figurines and all and post it's
still I don't know man just cuz I you
know I think I'm just like inside I'm
just I feel like such a normal guy I'm
also somewhat of an introvert too so
it's always just kind of surprising he's
very
shy okay now okay how physically demic
was the role of
drag
um it was some Lu but you know that's
that's always been the easy part for me
you know I'm a physical guy I've always
you know working out has always been
it's kind of been my thing it's been my
release for my therapy so it's something
I've always done so physically it you it
wasn't it wasn't as tough it was as it
was as just stretching myself as an
actor because it's still all kind of
kind of new to me and you know such a
large role and I was Ste you know
sitting on stage with some of the best
most talented people in the world uh
actors and directors just I me it was
very challenging but it was more
challenging you know and an active St on
physical well I just want you know Dave
that uh you're an inspiration to a lot
of people in Southeast Asia especially
the children and that know this we are
always rooing to you thank you very much
all right another big hand for D
please all right our next St worked with
James on her character very very early
on to add several Shades to soda in the
movie she is fearless in her own because
she doesn't want to be liked all the
time now Gamora we know from the comics
is a deadly green skinned assassin Zoe
Sana says she is attracted to the
unimaginable stories and places Now Zoe
welcome to Singapore big hand for
Zoe super excited to see here this is
your first visit here right right first
time Singapore yes but I've been dying
to come here for a very very long time
okay enjoying it so far yes yeah you
guys arrived last night huh did you
arrive last night um yesterday morning
actually we arrived at 3:30 in the
morning and uh we didn't go to bed until
8:00 because we were watching uh the
game
um yes and then this morning I woke up
at 3 because I had to watch the game so
I'm happy to say that Argentina Meed to
okay so what's your prediction for the
final then Argentina and
Germany
yes I think you're like a lot of us we
don't want to jinx it oh my God no okay
all right now uh zo what was the
audition process like uh for you for
this role of gamor um this time around
you would think it's easier when you
just get a phone call by a director and
tells you you are the only choice that
I've had for this character so please
read the script and tell me what you
think and it would be awesome to have
you on board you feel very very blessed
the first the first thing that you feel
is flattered super blessed your ego gets
a little like peaked as well and then
the second thought is absolute panic
because it means that if you say yes
there's a lot of expectations lying on
your shoulders uh because work that
you've done before has brought the
attention of of this awesome director
and he's relying on you delivering what
what he's seen you deliver before that
he's thought was so cool so you do you
kind of think um I I was a little
nervous when they said yes and then they
told me about the 5 and 1 half hours of
makeup every day and then they told me
about shooting it for 5 months and we
were going to be shooting it for six day
weeks and um and there was going to be a
lot of action and fighting and
rehearsals and and I thought okay
yes but I kind of went like okay yes
I'll do it I'll do it like I didn't want
to like like realize what I was getting
myself into and ended up being a great
experience because it had everything of
what I grew up wanting movies to have it
had action it had comedy um it had a lot
of
imagination and um and the story was
really complete and all the characters
had such a beautiful Journey um uh from
the beginning to end individually but
also as a collective and I and I thought
this is a great Ensemble picture to be a
part of right um you know I just I just
want to thank I think on behalf of all
the uh you know members of the press
year because I mean I I do a radio show
as well and uh you know I've seen the
17-minute clip that uh these guys caught
this morning and I couldn't help talking
about it on my radio show and I hope all
of you do the same in your articles
after to seeing the 17 minute because it
was it was hilarious there was action I
was just blown away I could wait for it
to open here in Singapore on the 31st of
July so um once again thank you very
much to uh people at Marvel and uh
Disney and uh you know you guys taking
time off your busy you who come
down and S the sou s FES T and uh we're
going to end the session here on stage
with one last question and and this is
for James um could you just tell us a
little bit more about Marvel's Guardians
of the G
that's a big
question listen I mean I really think
that Guardians of the Galaxy is a movie
for everybody it's a a movie that's
about the Galaxy and I think that we're
living in a time when there's so many
problems in our world uh there's so many
problems between different countries
around the world and Guardians is really
about a group of outcasts a group of
people who feel like they don't belong
coming together finding something within
themselves that they didn't know that
was there something heroic something
wonderful and very simply something good
and I think this is a movie about the
good in all of us no matter what country
we're from no matter what part of the
world we're from no matter whether we're
rich or poor it is a movie about the
love of ourselves and each other and
finding the good within ourselves and if
there's anything that makes this movie
worthwhile you know making and spending
two years of Our Lives moving nothing
else but this film is for people to be
able to walk out of the theater feeling
a little bit better about themselves
feeling a little bit better about the
person they were sitting next to in the
theater only know a little bit better
about the world in general and I hope
that's something that we can do and I
hope it's something that we can do to
continue to protect not only you know
the United States but the entire world
the entire galaxy and I hope that the
Guardians can continue to do that after
this film part two
everybody
all right ladies and gentlemen once
again James Zoe and Dave give them a big
hand
everybody all right bye-bye we'll see
you guys at the red CET on
Saturday I love you too
dve I'm sorry see we didn't we didn't
prepare
this my God that backf I'm going to get
it backstage do going to slam me on the
ground recho me no it's time for the uh
Q&A session right now okay but before we
carry on once again please no personal
questions uh just keep it to uh
questions about the movie and about
Marvel and uh I would like you can ask
personal questions to me that's fine
anything you want to know about my love
life about my cat I'm an open
book ask away I'll give you all the
glory
details okay you heard the director all
right I'd like to request that um you
you mentioned the name of your media
organization okay before you ask your
questions and of course please introduce
yourself as well we have people walking
around with the microphone so as soon as
you raise your hand we'll come up to you
with the microphone okay all right so
let's start this Q&A session all right
uh choose between one of those two SE it
next to each other we're together okay
you're going to be asking the question
together where are you guys from um I'm
Jill e Josh we're from FM so you guys
look cool thank you love your look show
awesome okay first question is that do
you like the hair yes it's approved
Hollywood approved yes all right zo I
like okay so we saw the footage loved it
where do we sign up for the
sequel cuz that's where the money is I
think the easiest way to sign up for the
sequel is buying a ticket to go see this
film and
that's making the sequel
woo all right okay so I been a dream of
my since I was a little kid to arm
wrestle Bautista and now that you're
here and you know what since Jill is
here you want to take on Zoe yeah it's
been my dream for 2 seconds minut wait
wait I'm a
southpaw I'm left handed o are you like
can we do left can you do left-handed
bring it oh let's do this marble
universe versus cor y'all let's do this
can we do this let's do this you guys
want to do it now let's do it now
questions do it do
it you guys have you and Dave you and
Dave I saw a guy I saw a guy that this
is true at the rap party that guy was
physically assaulting a girl at the rap
party and Dave protected this young lass
and the guy came running a Dave and Dave
just kind of hit him like this he
touched him just with the base of his
heel and the guy flew 20 ft not that's
not a joke that's totally true so so is
why if you want to keep your arm I would
suggest not uh not
right i'm James I I'm not approving
this what color are you going to be in
your next movie cuz you've been blue
green I got my money on
red um well because of because of um of
my my engagements with Avatar I think
I'm going back to Blue before I hit red
but if I ever hit red I'll let you guys
know thank you thank you guys thank you
thank you so
much all right next
question how about this gentleman right
here hi Al from J newspaper um Zoe are
the only female in the in the the main C
how do it feel be like you know leting
the wom the better for the Guardians all
that
it feels great and and um it's
empowering because I know that it brings
out it delivers a very strong message to
young women that besides being beautiful
and delicate flowers that you can also
Channel your your strength and not be
afraid of it and um it this is very
rewarding when you know that you can you
can climb a tree or you can grab a
weapon and even though we're we're in
the world of make believe uh you can you
can see yourself kind of doing all these
things and and you feel very empowered
um I'm actually very happy to say that
I'm not the only female in this cast
that Karen Gillan like really did an
amazing job and it felt really great to
know that I was I was sharing screen
time with not only amazing male actors
but also with another you know female
actress because sometimes being the only
female to get a little lonely you see
your sister join you in guard too maybe
yes oh I have two sisters so I'm pretty
sure that they be awesome if both of
them can join and and they can they can
learn to to fight
hereo Karen and Zoe were a lot of fun to
watch on set because they have a huge
fight scene with these two superpowered
females fighting each other and they're
like two female pH Woods like talk
battling it out and going and then all
of a sudden I'll say cut and then they
both
go
that's
true thank you thank you next
question gentleman over
here and uh maybe we can get ready the
next question that that guy over there
so James now that you've made a crazy
multi-million dollar Blockbuster for a
major corporation are you ever going to
go back for making something next sther
which is one of my favorite um I made
that movie for a major corporation also
I made that for Universal uh just a
smaller movie um you know I I I really
do whatever I feel like doing in the
moment and so I'm not sure what I'm
going to do next you know um it could be
another Marvel movie or it could be
something else that comes up at the last
minute I pretty much do what I believe
and I don't approach a small movie like
Slither super any differently than I
approach a big movie like Guardians of
the Galaxy I do everything I can fully
with my heart as true as I possibly can
and I've been very fortunate in my
career thus far to have producers like
Marvel who have let me kind of have free
reign and do something really creative
and excellent even though it's made for
such a large budget thank you where you
from I'm Phil from C City the
Philippines welcome thank you next
question this gentleman over here after
that Mr Bobby Kelli from cl5 please uh
hi I'm Jed young F magazine Singapore um
I wanted to ask of all the movies in the
Marvel Universe it feels like uh
Guardians of the Galaxy is the one of
the most obscure Source material in the
comics so did you feel extra pressure to
prove that this could work or were you
encouraged by the oddb nature of the
premise and really went went notated I I
feel like because Guardians of the
Galaxy in the comics they aren't as well
known as say Captain America or Iron Man
or The Avengers I felt like that gave us
a lot of freedom to really create
The Cinematic version of Guardians of
the Galaxy and I think that Guardians of
the Galaxy is more at home on screen
than it is in the comic books and it is
first and foremost a cinematic property
so I felt like it gave me a lot of
freedom to really do something
interesting with it and create lovable
characters like Zoe and Dave and you
know every all the whole
guys did you just say lovable his yeah
lovable I mean they're they're bunch of
bunch of a-holes but there're still
they're still lovable even
drafts Bobby thanks same radio station
by the way class 95 uh James it's
interesting because the Marvel Universe
right now is getting so big and
especially this is the I believe the
last Marvel movie till we go into
Avengers 2 the age of old Tron how much
uh did you work with Jos Sweden on this
and how much pressure was there from
Marvel to kind of get this movie to the
next
space of the Marvel
Universe well I felt like I'm very
fortunate in creating the first leg of
the Marvel Cosmic brand of Marvel Comics
so our hope would be that we can create
many more movies that are in the Marvel
Cosmic Universe um I think Josh and I
have been friends for a long time um
Josh read the script gave me notes on
the script and the biggest note he gave
was to make it more James gun and I said
it's your funeral and that's what I did
um um so that was J's input basically
and then also we had to work together in
casting Thanos because Thanos is going
to appear in stuff that I do as well as
stuff J does um but other than that I
pretty much had free reign and and it
wasn't so much having to make this movie
lead somewhere it was more creating a
really great foundation so that it could
lead somewhere because we don't want to
have to just fill in the dots we want to
create something that is substance and
that we believe in and that is very
exciting real and true and give a lot of
answers and then some of the answers we
leave unanswered so that there's places
to go for the Guardians to go in future
you know adventures together all right
thank you thanks just going to be
talking about this entire thing on this
show at 8:00 tonight I'm sure next
question
please that gentleman over
there hi my name is Z from just sayg um
just a question because um as you said
you got a lot of beeway this time but
say Drax as a character throughout the
comics he's been played many different
ways um he's
been strong like a space hwk he's been
dumb he's been not so bright very
bright what kind of Dr are we going to
see in this movie I mean you saw the
70-minute
clip he looked like a really
straightforward person but what's he
like that's good for for day he is in
you know that's kind of a that was a
hard part for me in the beginning there
was really no reference to Drax Drax has
changed so much throughout the years it
was it was hard to S it's kind of weird
now CU I think I'll be the reference for
Drax for years to come but the greatest
thing about Drax is he is a very literal
character which leads to a lot of good
laughes but I think he he is I I always
tell people the way I describe because
she's always describing this this
Warrior who held that's on ra I always
say that not at the core of dra St heart
over you know part over his family he's
he's this very honorable guy but he's
just uh he's very literal and there is
that uh that ins side just that
sociopath side he doesn't I don't think
Drax knows and it's it's wrong D to kill
people SE wrong he doesn't you know but
you know that's that's a great thing
about D you know he's he's actually you
know he's got a a heart that's figure
than his brain uh he's very little care
journey is just I think that cor just
hard thank you
chair next
question uh one of the
two same question are you guys asking
the sure all right um hi I'm n from
Yahoo um this question goes to zo and
Dave um we know that you all had to go
through hours of uh get your makeup done
so what what's going through your mind
uh while waiting for the makeup to get
done and what do you have to do to pass
the
time
um well it was five months so I'm pretty
sure that on month one there were a lot
of things going through my head and then
by five months four there were other
things going in K James
gun there um you know I I thought that
it was going to be harder but it really
wasn't we we were also working with
amazing makeup artists and so you walk
in and they create such a beautiful and
Serene space and you pick a playlist
sometimes or you talk about something or
you pass out
um and then you wake up and you're green
and that was actually interesting the
first week of trying to get used to that
green makeup and I think I did pass out
I was trying to deal with the jet lag
coming from the states and working in
England and and I passed out and I woke
up and it was it really it caused such
an impression that I kind
of took a moments I was like oh my God
what happened to my face like I forgot
that I was I had said yes I was here
doing the Guardians um no it was it was
actually fine except when when when they
when they would bring you earlier than
they would bring
catering
so You' be hungry for like hours before
the kitchen was open and then probably
would I don't know if it made you mad it
made me
crazy we we did have a couple of those
like 2:30 300 a.m. call times but you
know for me it's just I'm by Nature very
person so I literally just soaked out
just gone so and I it was a cool thing
because I liked closing my eyes and I
wasn't dra opening my eyes and I was dra
just kind of
cool he was I was very curious cuz we
were we were getting done in different
trucks it's like so how how's Dave how's
Dave dealing with it CU usually I heard
that men just freak out like oh no he's
the most Z he just stands there and I'm
like oh really so I had to kind of bring
my game on cuz at least I was sitting
sitting on a chair comfy chair laying
down whatever he was supposed to be he
was standing up right the whole time for
like 4 hours like
this purchas I can put my arms on like
what does he do go meditates I'm like oh
God
[Applause]
I couldn't meditate I just I would just
put on Little Dragons band that's
it okay another question hi I'm actually
from the new paper um this question is
for Dave um Dave I read that when you
got the RO you were so
overwhelmed some tears were shed is is
true and um can you share with me what
happened I the truth I I literally broke
down it wasn't a
few I was driving I was driving I was
like on my way to the gym surprise
surprise I was on my way to the gym and
my manager called he's my manager his
name is John Myer he's my best friend in
the world we've known each other 26 27
years and he's been with me throughout
my career he's my rock um so he called
me and and he said uh hold on for a
second he what tell me what time what's
going on and he got my agent on the
phone and he said congratulations Mr
Drex and I literally just broke down I I
drove home I was just a mess and people
love this story for some reason I know
they amused by by hearing me say that I
broke down tears but it was a big deal
to me and I I think you know I can never
explain to people
how how big this was for me it was a
life changing thing for me it was it was
hard for me to leave behind wrestling
and I work struggle and work struggle
and audition audition you finally got
the dream Ro of Lifetime that it was
like you know make a break I I pretty
much you know I lost everything that I
gained you know during wrestling I I
lost it all because I took a chance of
myself CU I had this passion for acting
I wanted to pursue it so I literally
just I me there was a few tear I'm
probably say that I throw it down it
that that's why I think inspiration for
a lot of
people
crun yeah it was it was really touching
I mean I think for all of us I think you
know I think of all the great moments
that I've had throughout the process of
making this movie but one of the best
moments for me was talking to Dave on
the phone like right after that and
calling you and talk to you and you're
just you're I'm like what are you doing
you're like I don't know what I'm doing
I'm I'm just driving around in a cloud I
don't know what's going on
and it was like it it was it was really
wonderful and you know from the
beginning sometimes you meet actors who
you really like as people and you really
want to give them the role but they
aren't right for the role and and you
don't do it you really give the role to
the person or Le I who's who's who
deserves the role and from the moment I
met Dave he and I had a sort of
connection like within minutes of
talking I sort of got day and I like
them so much as a person I was rooting
for him to come through through a series
of screen tests and a lot of different
things he had to go through to try to
get the role and when he actually you
know proved himself to be by far not you
know just slightly p forat and the only
person we've ever offered the role to is
Dave batist despite some stuff in the
press that has been said Dave is the
only person we've ever offered the role
to because he's the very best and when
he actually you know was that good it
was so so touching to me that I got to
make somebody and I think I feel this
way about all the cast were people who I
liked as people but that also were the
best people for the role and I think one
of the things about Guardians of the
Galaxy I was talking earlier about it's
about this group of odd balls and odd
casts who you know were plucked from you
know small obscurity and Marvel Comics
and turned into these big movie stars
and I think I that we we've talked about
this a lot that we all feel like that
I'm a guy who's made my last movie cost
$3 million he was an independent film
you know Dave is a a wrestler who people
didn't think of as a real actor you know
Zoe has been pushed to the sidelines her
whole life because she's a person of
color from a place that not everybody is
from in this industry Chris Pratt was a
chubby guy when he got this role you
know you know Vin Diesel's a weirdo and
benio just like
us the
ring you know for some reason everybody
thought they would be an easy
transition wrestling and AC couldn't be
any more different they couldn't be any
more different and it wasn't easy
transition at all you know I think
that's the first time I actually because
my first I I did to a friend for a
friend and was when I realized U two
things one was how hard it was and two
that I loved it and I wanted to pursue
it but there's just not even similarity
the only similarity would be that you
know there's C point that that's it
that's where it
is wrestling is so big so so
conversation
andness so
much thank you well thank you very much
and we have our Rousy
round
[Applause]
for
and thank you so so much thank you hey
rocket rocket in the
house okay right now we're going to have
a grou picture on stage okay so
photographers get
ready W that's that's really close guys
we like maybe two steps back like two
two steps
back